what do you think is the most amazing or
maybe the coolest measurement device
you've ever worked with or humans have
ever built maybe for now let's exclude
the background imaging of cosmic
extragalactic polarization instruments
yeah i'm slightly biased towards that
particular instrument but talk about
that in a little bit yeah but certainly
the telescope to me is is a lever that
has literally moved the earth uh
throughout history the og telescope og
telescope yeah the one invented not by
galileo as most people think but by this
guy hans lipperche in uh in the
netherlands
and you know it was kind of interesting
because
in the 1600s 14 1500 1600s it was the
beginning of movable type and so people
for the first time in history uh had a
standard by which they could appraise
their eyesight so looking at a printed
word now we just take it for granted 12
point font whatever and that's what the
eye charts are based on they're just
fixed height but back then there were no
there's no way to adjust your eyesight
if you didn't have uh you know perfect
vision and there was no way to even tell
if you had perfect vision or not until
the gutenberg bible and movable type and
at that time people realized hey wait i
can't read this you know my priest or my
my friend over here he can read it she
can read it i can't read it what's going
on and that's when you know these people
in in venice and in the netherlands saw
that they could take this kind of you
know glass material and hold it up and
maybe put another piece of glass
material and it would make it clearer
and what was so interesting is that
nobody thought to take that exact same
device you know two lenses and go like
let me go like this and look at that
bright thing in the sky over there
until galileo so galileo didn't invent
it but he
did something kind of amazing he
improved on it by a factor of 10. so he
10xed it which is almost as good as
going from zero to one is going from you
know one to ten
and
when he did that he really
transformed both how we
look at the universe and think about it
but also who we are as a as a species
because we're using tools not to get
food faster or to you know preserve you
know uh our our legacy for the for
future generations but actually to
increase the benefit of to the human
mind
somebody mentioned this idea that um
if humans weren't able to see the stars
maybe there was some some kind of
make above the atmosphere which
for the early humans made it impossible
to see the stars that we would never
develop human civilization or at least
raising the question of how important is
it to look up to the sky and wonder
what's out there as opposed to
um maybe this is an over romanticized
notion but like looking at the ground it
feels like a little bit too much focused
on survival not being eaten by a bear
slash lion
if you look up to the stars you start to
wonder what is my place in the universe
you think i think that's uh modern
humans romantic it's a little romantic
um because they also took the tried
they took the same two lenses and they
looked inward right they looked at
bacteria they looked at you know hairs
and in other words they made the
microscope and we're still doing that
and so you know to have a telescope is
it serves a dual purpose it's it's not
only
a way of looking out it's looking in but
it's also looking back in time in other
words you can see a microscope you don't
say oh i'm seeing this thing as it was
you know one nanosecond ago light
travels one foot per nanosecond uh i'm
seeing it no you don't think about it
like that but when you see something
that's happening you know on jupiter the
moon andromeda galaxy you're seeing
things you know back when lucy was
walking around the serengeti plains
and for that i think that took then the
knowledge of you know relativity and
time travel and and so forth it took
that before we could really say oh we we
really unlocked some cheat codes in the
human brain so i i think that might be a
little too much but but nevertheless i
mean what's better than having a time
machine you know it's like we can look
back in time we see things as they were
not as they are and that allows us to do
many things including speculate about
that but one of the coolest things i
don't know if you're familiar with so
i'm a radio astronomer i don't actually
look through telescopes very often uh
except uh you know on rare occasions
when i when i take one out uh to show
the kids but
um but a radio telescope is even more
sort of visceral i mean it's much less
cool because you look at it you're like
all right it looks cool it's kind of
weird shaped thing looks like it belongs
in sci-fi it's going to blast you know
the death star or whatever but when you
when you realize that when you point a
radio telescope at a distant object if
that object fills up what's called the
beam which is basically the
field of view of a radio telescope it's
called this beam if you fill up the beam
and you put a resistor just a simple
absorbing piece of material at the focus
of the radio telescope that resistor
will come to the exact same temperature
as the object it's looking at
which is pretty amazing it means you're
actually remotely measuring you're
taking the temperature of jupiter or
whatever in in effect and so it's it's
it's allowing you to basically teleport
and there's no other science that you
can really do that right if you're an
archaeologist you can let me get into my
you know my time machine and go back and
see what was lucy really like you know
it's not possible so this the same thing
happens this is where i've learned about
this from march of the penguins when the
penguins huddle together
they uh you know the body temperature
arrives to the same place so you're
you're doing this remotely
the march of the penguins but remote we
do it from antarctica too so there are
some penguins around when we do it
you